did you tell your mother you're taking a
pregnancy test you memorize my ovulation
schedule it's it I forgot to give you a
raise is in there and then that way
gravity pulled his semen into my uterus
right I just have her do a handstand
how's that we've been trying to get
pregnant since we got married
we've got to face the facts what we've
been doing it's not working do you think
we've been doing it wrong
we should try reverse cowgirl as a woman
this is the one thing I'm supposed to be
able to do and I can't do it go see a
doctor and if it doesn't work out I'll
give you one of my kids hard pass okay
let's talk about your uterus is one of
the finest specimens I've ever seen
blessing when did you last have a sperm
analysis I'm sorry what I don't know if
I can do it I don't know if I can
perform creamy perfor it's not karaoke
if it actually do allow wives to assist
oh oh this is like the set of a song
movie
we're trying to all these things and
nothing's working
oh it's like a little bit lumpy going
down and I'm pumping cating up with all
these drugs like she's some racehorse
just don't tell me when you're gonna do
it just do it no tell me when you're
gonna do it don't tell me when you're
gonna do it no tell me when you're there
it is
I did it I've got a good feeling about
this Oh life isn't something that should
be ordered from a catalogue how do you
have a thought of alternative methods
and what is the package include Nano
acupressure a lunar fornication calendar
sorry what was that last part it's an
app it sounds an alarm when it's time to
smash I'm in we're in I didn't know that
having babies with you Matt not having
sex with you getting hand jobs and Trent
Reznor's kill room most cops hate when
perps run by I enjoy that brisk cardio
blast of a foot race nothing in life is
fair maybe right now you are not meant
to have kids baby you are not a baby it
does not matter if I don't have you what
kind of under slacks do you wear boxers
or briefs
you
you